You know,
you can't let the orderliness part of
you get the upper hand so terribly that
it's impossible for you to live.
That's what happens to girls who have
had [inaudible] by the way.
You know how you get.
There's this idea with regards to
anorexia that it's often high achieving
girls who have it and while it's hyper
conscientious girls,
they get so disgust sensitive.
They can't stand their own bodies and so
for example,
then they start being able to look at
their bodies properly and so what they
do instead of looking at their whole
body,
they lose the ability to do that.
They only can see parts of their body
and then they can't tell the difference
between a part that's healthy and well
shaped and a fat part and so anything
that's that's,
that's what would you call of dubious.
Anything that's hard to measure becomes
impossible to see.
So either an anorexic client at one
point,
she wasn't a very big woman maybe about
this big and thin.
Yes,
obviously.
And so I was trying to work with her on
her body perception disorder and one of
the things I did was,
so I had her come and sit beside me,
so I was sitting like this and so is
she.
And I said,
well you look at our two thighs,
which one is bigger?
Like mine was like 40 percent bigger.
And she said,
well I can't tell they look the same to
me.
And so I said,
okay,
this is what we're going to do.
I let her do it.
I said,
you take a pencil and also done a piece
of paper and you just trace my thigh.
Okay.
And then you can put that piece of paper
underneath your thigh and trace it and
then you can look at the difference.
Well,
so I had her do that and she looked at
the two pieces of paper and she couldn't
believe it.
She could not believe that that was
actually the case because her perception
had become so disordered that it was
impossible for her to see the real shape
of her body.
And we would go outside and I would ask
her,
you know,
is that person,
is that person fat and with other people
she could tell,
but with her own body,
not a chance.
She couldn't see it properly at all.
And so there was a real obsession with
purity among women who have anorexia and
all,
they'd like to starve themselves right
down to the bone because the bone is
sort of pure and white and there's no
excess tissue on it.
And so anorexia also looks like a
disease of disgust.
So it's very,
very difficult to.
She she thought and very black and white
terms.
One of the things I had her do at one
point was said she hasn't music.
She said,
I either really like a song or I don't
like it at all.
And I said,
okay,
well you've got a music collection,
why don't you go through like 20 of
those songs and rate them on a scale
from one to 10.
And she couldn't do it.
It was either yes or no orderly,
right?
The boundaries around the categories
were absolutely segregated.
And her apartment tended to be decorated
in black and white and she was hyper
clean,
you know,
so everything in the apartment was
extraordinarily orderly,
well put away.
She couldn't stand to see anything
disgusting on the counters and that sort
of thing.
So very,
very difficult disorder to treat
anorexia very,
very difficult.
So,
and you know,
you can see how it can go wrong because
food,
when you're eating your disgust systems
are on alert,
you know,
like you,
you want the thing you want to and you
absolutely don't want the thing you
don't want to eat and your mouth is very
sensitive to that sort of thing.
You know the texture and all of that and
your sense of smell is very sensitive to
that sort of thing because you know,
you don't want to eat anything that's
contaminated or poisonous.
So it's another situation like sex where
the reward system is driving you forward
for,
to engage in a consumer story behavior.
But the disgust system is right there,
mo modulating and moderating it.
And there's a tension between those two
things.
That's already always at work.
And with the anorexic types,
the disgust sense of disgust system gets
the upper hand.
So she was also extraordinarily
judgemental and perfectionistic.
But that goes along with it because
orderly people are judgemental and
perfectionistic.
And so if you're,
you're a perfectionist,
often what that means is you have very
high levels of orderliness and very high
levels of neuroticism.
And those two things chase each other
around like mad because you can't stand
the idea that you would make a mistake
and you get anxious about it as well.
So then you get stuck in this
perfectionistic mindset and you can't
get out of it.
So.